Joe Biden has a problem he's a hoarder
but instead of collecting trinkets or
stamps the big guys into classified
documents the FBI searched Biden's home
for 13 hours this weekend and found even
more secret files some of which date
back to his time in the Senate over a
decade ago keep in mind this is the same
house that Biden's lawyers said they'd
already searched
and the feds aren't done new Reports say
the FBI's next stop in the search for
missing secret files could be Biden's
Beach getaway even some senior Democrats
are growing sick of the BS
when that information is found it
diminishes the stature of any person who
is in possession of it because it's not
supposed to happen whether it was a the
fault of a staffer or an attorney it
makes no difference the elected official
Bears ultimate responsibility you know
the way
the real problem that these documents
are somewhere they shouldn't be
Republicans are demanding answers but
they might not get what they want the
Biden doj dragging its feet on
cooperating one Republican lawmaker says
it looks like a cover-up and when
pressed the White House left the door
open
is President Biden involved in a
cover-up
we have been very clear here from
this Administration the president has
been very clear
that he takes this very seriously
that's a good question by Ducey it is a
great question that's really good
questions yeah and guess what it's
Monday and she still has no good answers
well she's clear about vegetarians let
us be very clear these are not good
answers but which means to me that
either she didn't demand them
or there just are no good answers and
that the chief of staff who is now going
to be leaving and there's a new Chief of
Staff coming in hasn't either told the
president that your press secretary is
out there with nothing to defend her
there's nobody other as I said where's
Kamala Harris where remember when people
were mad that John Kirby was getting up
and doing joint briefings with her
because I felt that was taking away from
her
Authority in the briefing room I I you
know I would agree with that except for
that if you don't give her anything to
work with
and I find it interesting when she when
she pounded the podium there in a way I
think she's not mad at anybody in the
briefing room she understands what's
going to happen because right now you
could say there are zero days since the
White House has not been caught lying
about or providing a lack of information
not being transparent or not even
knowing what the heck is going on I also
think that blaming the staff is a really
bad thing so one of the things that
happened last week when we found out
that there were documents in the Penn
Biden Center in that office there was a
accusation that the staffer Kathy Chung
that that was the person that she packed
up the office with her fault no actually
it's
now we know that there are documents or
items we don't know how many it could be
a box from his Senate days Kathy Chung
didn't work for him when he was Senator
and so I think when you are somebody who
is willing to throw your staff under the
bus or let your staff twist in the wind
without giving them more that that is
not leadership and they've got
probably more shoes to drop yep judge
where were you on Saturday late morning
when you look at your phone and another
batch of documents have been recovered
from the Biden house it's stupid I
remember I remember and I said to myself
I remember Jesse saying and this isn't
the end of it and Jesse was so right and
I I compliment you for that I really do
look Joe Biden is a liar
he is a repeated uh plagiarist he's a
Serial plagiarist he had to drop out of
presidential races because he lied about
who he was but as a senator he took
documents from a skiff and when you come
out of a skiff those documents are
supposed to be returned he took them as
a senator he had no right as a vice
president he took documents he had no
right to take those documents and now we
know he's got documents from 10 years
ago from 14 years ago as a senator all
of these documents are in different
places various locations what was he
doing with them they're not supposed to
be in different locations do the
location suggest that he was dealing
with different issues in different
places and the truth is this this
Republican oversight has to
cross-reference the Biden family
businesses with the documents where they
were because we already know the Penn
Biden Center at documents from Ukraine
UK in the UK and I want to know about
China were any of those documents from
China when they were doing business the
fact that they're spread around in
different locations concerns me what do
you think the chances are that Hunter
Biden took a glance at some of these
documents good to excellent he lived
there
sorry I don't know I I assume that the
next argument will be that he was
probably high and drunk and when you're
high and drunk you don't really want to
be reading classified materials in your
dad's garage but I don't know we'll find
out and that's the point of all of this
and there's there's definitely been a
sea change in certain in terms of the
democratic response to us Tim Kaine
um senator from Virginia who thankfully
announced that he was going to seek
re-election because that was another
seat that we don't have trouble
defending said you know I'm a senator
top Senator on these committees I only
look in a skiff right at these documents
and then I give them back and then I
leave
um Mark Warner on the Intel committee
has said we've got to know what's going
on here these are key allies Dick Durbin
these are people who were with Joe Biden
from the jump in this in terms of the
primary what it'll come down to is in
the court of public opinion at least and
for Merrick Garland ultimately in the
end but do you believe that the
obstruction issue which so far Donald
Trump has but Joe Biden doesn't have
makes these not comparable
I believe they're very different in the
fact that the Trump group stonewalled
The National Records Office the FBI the
doj makes a huge difference and they
eventually had to get a warrant to go in
and take out the documents I think that
makes it different but there is
frustration out there about how the
Biden team is handling this just tell us
were you writing a book were you writing
your Memoir what was going on why did
you have them there could be simple
answers to this even if it was
carelessness I shouldn't have done it
some sort of apology and acknowledgment
that something went wrong in this
process would go a long way but it's the
director trip is bad The Ghost Writer
would then have the classified documents
he doesn't write his own stuff Greg you
want to hear what my source is inside
Rehoboth Beach are telling me I'm dying
to hear they witnessed the big guy
tossing classified documents into the
ocean before the feds could get down to
the beach house really your sources
highly placed amazing amazing wow I bet
we'll never be able to validate that at
all or verify we couldn't do it with the
Russia hooks either yeah that is true
you know uh to be fair he did the Biden
Joe Biden did agree to a consensual
search although he thought it would be
something else
showed up with a bottle of Jergens you
know you brought up hoarders it's not
hoarders this is not horses hoarders is
where they keep everything right bidens
lose everything yeah so you need to do a
reality show called losers and it's
people that lose things whether it's
laptops Diaries handguns documents crack
pipes of the crack pipes brain cells
hair follicles they are the they are the
family of losers they are the they are
they're you know what hoarders would
look down on them because they're not
keeping their stuff together but I mean
there are there are basically five key
elements here I'm not going to go
through them but when you add it up
there's this incredible intersection
that you end up with because you why was
this delayed that's the that's the big
question too I was like uh what's in the
documents how many documents but this
intersection of a junkie doing deals
with our adversaries like China ends up
coincidentally in the very same room
where there are secret documents just
lying about that are adversaries that
he's dealing with would love and pay a
high price for that I mean that could
all be coincidental right it's just like
how did the bullet end up in the in
Baldwin's gun but
but probably look at it and find out
yeah yeah but I mean you did dismiss it
I did not I said let's set it out of
hand young lady out of hand in hand
yes I like that
yeah I wanna Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now